les cherry on va tout de suite joué avec
rohff on va jouer à rock boyard d'accord
of boyard vous allez affronter deux
chroniqueurs et chimène badi dans trois
épreuves de fort boyard
alors attention ce sont des poids de 2
kg il faut rester comme ceci donc de 6
kg pas de 6 kg c'est vrai faut rester le
plus longtemps prostré assez longtemps
c'est le plus longtemps possible bras
tendus rolala les regards des regrets le
plus longtemps possible
ces barques ou [ __ ]
j'adore ça a l'air hyper lourd
j'adore
bon ça la salle mathieu et pierre
mathieu souffre déjà purgé magazine more
of d'un kg est les gars je maîtrise
[Musique]
aussi va craquer oracle ou db2 craqué à
l'est
trans piranhas
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine jean luc lemoine
fatakhov encore en fait on lui fait tout
faire alors attention chacun votre tour
vous allez taper sur le clou avec un
celui qui termine par enfoncer le clou
tu veux bien sûr toi celui qui termine
par enfoncer le clou à gagner entre fort
bonjour la ola
les gars je vous sens bricoleurs en
dollars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
o o cotation dans la tronche mais
jean-luc voilà il est minuit et demi et
c'est toujours d'attention des mines m
protat que l'autre fait l'autre fait
l'autre ces deux points je mets toi t'es
pas droit voilà allez aimer l'idée ont
perdu bien là non pas les deux mais ces
gens ne m'ont pas que tu fais oui oui je
peux
matin donnez-moi abandonné moi ce [ __ ]
de marteau c'est intense
voilà of metal à mon chéri je redresse
mais c'est pas possible que ces belles
séquences
bon allez c'est pas gagné mais semble
qu'elle bricoleur voilà la beauté de
planter un clou j'ai jamais vu un gars
ça n'aura laissé tomber la dernière
épreuve je la sens pas du tout les
laisser tomber
je vous avais fardeau royal jean-luc 3
wii web on n'y allait pas un si je peux
vous donner un conseil qu'il faut pas
faire c'était prévu comme ça va être une
catastrophe